Cloud Code is simple to install whether
you want to use it in your terminal, the
web, or your IDE.
If you're on macOS, Linux, or WSL, use
this curl command to install it in one
go.
If you prefer to use Homebrew, you can
also use brew install to install it, but
note that this doesn't have auto-update
capabilities. For Windows, there's also
a couple ways. In PowerShell, use the
Invoke-RestMethod command. If you're on
CMD, you can also use this curl command.
We also have a winget command as well if
you prefer, but just like Homebrew, it
won't auto-update.
Now, go to your project directory and
run cloud. You will go through some
initial instructions like choosing your
color theme and signing in with your
cloud account, which could be the pro,
max, or enterprise. Or you can use an
API key. If your organization has a
cloud enterprise account, be sure to
select that option. Whatever directory
you decide to run cloud in, it will have
access to that directory and all of its
subfolders.
In Visual Studio Code, open up your
extensions panel and search for Cloud
Code.
You will see the extension by Anthropic.
Make sure it has the blue check and hit
install. After installation, you might
need to restart VS Code. After that, you
can open up the control palette with
control or command and shift and P and
search Cloud Code. Open a new tab. You
can also click on the cloud logo if you
see it when a file is open. You can also
opt out of the UI and just use the
terminal experience directly in your
settings file.
For JetBrains IDEs, you can install the
Cloud Code plugin from the JetBrains
Marketplace.
Once you install, restart your IDE.
And when you reopen, you'll see the
cloud logo.
This will open up a pane where you can
see the terminal experience.
And this will work alongside you.
On Cloud Desktop, you can also run Cloud
Code.
After you install Cloud Desktop and
signed in, you will see a toggle at the
top that says code.
The look and feel is similar to Claude
chat side of things, but allows you to
work in a specific folder, change
permissions, and even work in a cloud
environment.
On the web, you can access Claude code
by going to claude.ai/code.
This works very similar to the desktop
app. However, you're restricted to
GitHub repositories only.
If you want to constantly keep up to
date with everything, the terminal is
the best bet. Features ship there the
fastest. For the most part, you'll have
extremely similar experiences with the
IDE integrations if you like Claude code
to feel more intertwined with your
favorite code editor.
Desktop is great for letting Claude run
in the background while you run other
tasks. Claude code on the web is a great
option if you want to remotely work on a
project through a GitHub repository or
have multiple sessions work in parallel.
However, you want to use Claude code,
it's up to you.